[Music]
thank you
[Music]
these are the best s-log picture profile
settings it's called portrait 800 it's
part of my Sony film simulation recipes
and today I will show you exactly how to
color grade it in under one minute
this is a quick color grading tutorial
and presentation of the best s-log
picture profile also called portrait 800
this is a profile that I've been working
on since My First Sony film simulation
recipes which is about two years now and
after a lot of shooting testing and
comparing different Gammas color modes
and settings I came to the conclusion
that if you're looking for great color
right out of camera this is the best
picture profile for s-log on any Sony
camera
this profile will give you better color
rendition less noise artifacts and
amazing skin tones you can find it on my
website it's part of my Sony film
simulation plan which costs only five
dollars per year and if you ask me it's
basically free because it includes all
updated 20 Sony film simulation recipes
together with all the color filter
settings that will give you the film
look
these are some shots from the last video
this is the before and this is the after
as you can see it looks amazing and has
really natural colors even though being
in nature we were surrounded by a lot of
green Hues you can notice how the
profile is rendering lovely skin tones
and the green cast is barely noticeable
you can find the settings to the updated
profile and all my other film simulation
settings on my website link in
description down below this is how the
footage looks straight out the camera it
has gorgeous colors and if you're
Overexposed it right at about 1.5 or 1.7
you will get the most out of this
profile with least amount of noise
if you ask me in many cases it's good to
go as it is the only thing that I like
to do is bring down the Shadows just a
little bit to hide more of a noise
located in the darker areas
maybe decrease the saturation and
increase the contrast just a bit to put
focus on the right things and let your
eyes fall where it's supposed to you can
do that by activating the splines in the
curves panel
and then in the left corner select the
Black Point and bring it down
also bring down the saturation to about
35 to give it a fitted look this is how
you make a basic grade simple and easy
the profile is so good it doesn't need
much post-processing to look natural and
with pleasing colors
now let me show you how you can get the
same look as in the original video to
grade this footage I use the creative
film power grades you can find the link
in the description down below
in the creative film powergrade you can
choose from 54 classic film color
presets 35 film contrast Gammas and
multiple halation effects and afterwards
you can export them as your own custom
Lots so let me show you how to use it
I'll use the Note 3 from the film pack
to make it easier
apply contrast of your choice and then
manually adjust it to your liking
next browse through all the classic film
colors and apply one
of my favorites is the scenic color the
name is an homage the first successful
color Motion Picture process which was
called Cinema color
let me know in the comments if you want
to find out more about that
now let's adjust the halation
there's something I forgot to mention in
my last video the creative film power
grades includes two types of fellation
effects The DaVinci Resolve plugin which
has my custom settings installed and
which is included in the no Tree by
default but this effect will work only
if you have a DaVinci Resolve license
but don't sweat it for those who don't
have a license for DaVinci Resolve I
included manual red holistic effect
it's in the resolution folder and if you
follow my previous tutorial on how
powerful DaVinci Resolve power grades
are you already have them imported if
not go check that video to learn how to
use power grades step by step from
scratch
you drag and drop the halation effect on
the Node and you can see the effect is
already showing now how to edit the
intensity of the effect right click on
the Node enter the compound node a
compound node is like a nest where you
group a node tree to make it tidier and
simplify the structure enter the
compound node and you will see we have a
couple nodes
check for the color space transform node
here you set the input gamma for meets s
lock 2 and the output set it to linear
be sure to check these settings to be
the same otherwise it's not going to
work then go to the second color space
transform choose input gamma linear and
output gamma whatever you have shot it
Rec 709 log mine is s-lock 2 so I'll put
s-lock 2 again now let's go to the layer
node which is this one and yours might
look a little bit different I've updated
the resolution effect but that's not a
problem to be sure it's the same let's
reset it and remake it from scratch this
activate the splines now select the
white point and drag it down completely
make a note in the middle of the spline
simply by pressing and now drag the
white point back let's say 25 percent of
the way
go into the blur panel and unlink the
colors so you can blur out the Reds now
drag the red all the way up and wait a
second to assess if it's too much we can
also drag green and blue to give a
different Hue variation to the halation
and there you have it this is how I
created the footage and I think the
creative film power grades made it so
much easier with all the presets I color
graded the footage in a couple of
minutes a job that could have taken me a
lot longer if you want to find out more
about color grading I invite you to my
online course which will help you easily
understand color grading in a short
period of time it's a group class which
I'll be holding next month in this
course I will guide you in the process
of creating your own footage and explain
different techniques that will make the
whole process easier to grasp all the
Lots will be provided at the end of the
course for free so go check it out save
your spot is going to be fun Link in
description also go check out my Sony
film simulations if you're interested in
that hope this helped clear out some
questions let me know in the comments
what you'd like to see next till then
and have fun and stay curious see ya
[Music]